exécuter pour le groupe démocrate
Monsieur Philippe Vigier
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission cher Guillaume Caden
cher rapporteur chez Jean-Paul Mathis
président du groupe démocrate chers
collègues
ces images auxquelles nous avons pu
assister tous entre le 27 juin et le 5
juillet sont des images dramatiques
c'est celle d'une république fragilisée
d'une république
qui a été déstabilisée pendant des
longues journées et d'abord moi je
voudrais naturellement avoir une pensée
pour la famille de ce jeune qui est mort
mais également avoir une pensée émue
pour toutes ces forces de l'ordre tous
ceux qui n'ont jamais lâché jour et nuit
pour faire en sorte que la paix revienne
et que le calme revienne et que l'on
soit en capacité d'avancer comme l'a dit
le ministre
le moment de l'analyse
le moment des enquêtes judiciaires
l'analyse de la politique de la ville et
je vous en dira un mot parce que j'ai en
partage avec Thierry Benoît le fait
d'être là depuis quelques années
dommage les députés écologistes ne sont
pas là mais je le dirai à la fin de mon
propos il faudra aussi savoir pourquoi
en mettant plus d'argent comme nous le
faisons depuis de longues années
monsieur le ministre et bien les
résultats ne soient pas à la hauteur
mais moi je n'oublie pas que ces images
que nous avons tous vues elles ont
touché 500 communes que ces images elles
ont abîmées détruits 750 bâtiments
publics ou privés et ayons aussi une
pensée émue pour ceux qui ont perdu leur
outil de travail pour le médecin
généraliste dans le cabinet a été brûlé
pour l'infirmière qui n'a plus de
voiture pour les enseignants qui n'ont
plus d'école
pour ce car qui a été brûlé ce bus
sanitaire dans lesquels on dépistait des
pathologies en particulier pour les
femmes toutes ces images c'est une
France défigurée et il faut monsieur le
ministre essayer tout votre honneur de
porter ce texte de le porter dans
l'urgence être en capacité naturellement
d'essayer de gommer les stigmates vous
avez fait le bon choix avec le
rapporteur parce que
avec Jean-Paul Mattei en matière
d'urbanisme de logement du construction
vous avez un orfèvre matière et je suis
persuadé que toutes les facilitations
après la prolongation des ordonnances il
vous les apportera
est-ce que nous sommes en train de faire
c'est un signal qu'on envoie au pays
est-ce que oui non lorsqu'il y a une
crise comme celle-là on est capable de
réagir rapidement ce que oui ou non là
où il y a lenteur
ceux qui sont maires qui l'ont été
savent que entre le moment où on dessine
un projet et au moment où on ouvre une
école il se passe trois ans C'est ça la
vraie vie de tous les jours le moment où
on réhabilite un commerce et qu'il est
public il se passe souvent plusieurs
mois et là le fait de au travers des
trois articles monsieur le ministre pour
la reconstruction des règles d'urbanisme
qui sont assouplis avec d'ailleurs une
garantie naturellement que on construira
avec des normes qui sont sur le plan
énergétique bien plus performantes que
nous avons auparavant tout ce que nous
allons faire sur les financements on a
mégarido vous hier en commission vous
étiez émis parce qu'il y a pas d'argent
nouveau d'abord je permets de vous
rappeler une chose
lorsque vous récupérez la TVA
immédiatement ça vous évite une
trésorerie voyez plutôt d'attendre
pendant deux ans ça c'est déjà de
l'argent public quand vous aurez géré
une collectivité vous verrez que ça se
passe comme ça et vous dire aussi que la
fongibilité des aides de l'État c'est
quelque chose d'exceptionnel qui
touchera le monde rural comme le monde
urbain c'est pour ça que je me suis
élevé en commission contre des
amendements où on voulait simplement
réserver de la fameuse 2/3 donc ce que
nous faisons sur les marchés publics où
on ne foule pas aux pieds le contrôle de
l'égalité madame Garrido bien au
contraire
il sera toujours là au final mais
faciliter les la loi sur la lotissement
faciliter la mobilisation de ces marchés
jusqu'à une somme dont vous parlerez
monsieur le ministre j'imagine un
million et demi d'euros fait que nous
apporterons une réponse très forte donc
ce texte et il faut le voter conforme
avec les sénateurs du meilleur qu'on
soit opérationnelle le plus rapidement
possible et j'imagine que vous aurez à
coeur que cette ordonnance sorte le plus
vite possible c'est une réponse qu'une
vaudons à la France assez mère que nous
vénérons tous les uns et les autres donc
on sait très bien que ce sont les
piliers de la République et bien ces
piliers ils doivent être confortés car
les Français nous regardent alors j'ai
été assez indigné car j'ai vu l'attitude
du rassemblement national qui est d'un
renoncement permanent ne pas voter un
tel texte je vous le dis ne pas voter à
tel texte parce que
parce que vous vous reconnaisses parce
que vous vouliez des mots requalifiant
ces violences urbaines la France saura
que vous n'avez pas voulu reconstruire
on va pas attendre quatre années pour
reconstruire il faut reconstruire
maintenant c'est votre responsabilité et
on leur dira
quand à la nups et aux écologistes c'est
dommage que Madame Chatelain ne soit pas
là moi j'étais député lorsqu'un
gouvernement de gauche a baissé de 13
milliards et demi d'euros au lieu de
dotations aux collectivités 13 milliards
et demi d'euros avec une politique de la
ville qui s'est effondrée de 40%, mais
quel kilos quelle honte
et bien vous devriez au moins au moins
au moins quand on sait la mobilisation
de l'État sur les fonds
[Applaudissements]
et dans un hémicycle apaisé pour
accueillir nos visiteurs nous allons
écouter 5